welcome back to my channel from Master
strategica today's episode is tiles and
ocean rebates So today we're going to
talk about optimal tile placements and
also we are going to talk about how to
get the maximum efficiency out of your
ocean rebates or ocean adjacency bonus
if you will so we're going to talk about
all three different Maps today we're
going to start with Elysium then we're
going to move on to tharsus which is the
base map and then headless and then
there are a few other topics I would
like to discuss like how to deny enemy
rebates and the ocean standard project
there are chapters in the description so
for example if you only care about the
base map which is fastest then you can
just go and find that chapter but let's
start off nice and basic there are two
types of people in this world they're
people who love plants and then there's
also people like Sarah man from Lord of
the Rings and I thought I like playing
some playing production I think it's
really good but recently I've been
spending some time with the top ELO
players on Steam and these guys they
really love plants so the timber players
who seek to end the game in as few
Generations as possible these guys will
just take the three plans and make a
bunch of greeneries next to Ocean and
it's even better if you can place down
the ocean next to the three plants as
your first action and then claim this
style as your second action because this
will give you plus two Mega credits it
could also be the tile right to the left
of this one let's say both of the oceans
and the middle have been made in that
case it makes a lot of sense to just
place it right there instead on the
other hand the greedy players will be
really tempted about grabbing these
three tasty cards up here and I know I
like to divide it into the greedy
playstyle and the timber play style
because it just makes a lot of sense for
me but of course you can mix and match
this however you want like naturally in
some cases the timber player will also
tend to take the three caps maybe they
just have bad cards at the beginning of
the game and at the same time the greedy
players might also build in the middle
of the map with all the plans here
because it's just a really good place to
be no matter what style you're playing
and then you might be thinking what
about this tile up here isn't this tile
also really good I actually had a huge
discount version with the tempo notes
not too long ago about this so
Inquisitor mentioned this tile in
particular and said isn't this really
good because it's adjacent to tiles that
can give you four four six six back in
Ocean rebates later in the game once the
oceans have been placed so he's talking
about these four spots here but then
anthracite was like one of the absolute
goats of this game he said well you
should not calculate the rebates
adjacent to the ocean and not add the
value for plants collected this area of
Elysium isn't even the best area on
Elysium as the two to three plant spots
in the middle are worth four to six Mega
credits by themselves and of course this
is a way to think about it like plants
are actually really valuable one plan is
worth around two Mega credits some of
the tempo notes will even argue with
even more than two Mega credits but just
for the sake of argument let's say a
plan is worth 2 Mega credits having this
in mind we should operate this tile here
so six Mega credits rather than 4 Mega
credits so if we apply this logic to the
middle of the map you can see here that
there's actually a lot of value to be
collected here it's definitely the best
place to be if you're valuing plans and
if you can get the oceans down around it
because these numbers here they are of
course if you get maximum ocean and
rebates so what about this tile here
with the three cards what is this tile
with so previously I've been saying that
random cars with three Mega credits and
in the two player games where you play
really greedies with around 4 Mega
credits but there's also this argument
to be made that if you're going all in
on terraforming if you just want to
close the game really quickly you're
playing a Tempo game and the cards in
your hand are already fine they're
already supporting the strategy then a
random card is not worth that much too
so in that case it could be accurate
that the random Card is only worth two
Mega credits and that also ties into the
storyline I'm trying to push here that
generally speaking the cards are just
better for greedy players the thing is
if you're playing this game where you
just want to end the game as soon as
possible then it is a little bit
dangerous to just pick up too many cards
because it kind of ruins your Tempo so
if you go back to the map and if you're
really pessimistic and card draw in
general and say random Card is only
worth two Mega credits well then this
title is kind of like worth 6 mega
credits before we calculate in the
rebates I think a more average for you
on how much a random card is worth is
more like three Mega credits in that
case it's nine and if you are a
completely greedy player and you're
playing the ultra greedy Uber card
strategy then in that case I would still
like you that a car is worth 4 Mega
credit but only in that case but let's
stick with three Mega credits for random
card I think most people will agree on
this but if we applying the logic from
before that we're just calculating in
the dream scenario the max ocean rebate
so we'll in that case if we place this
tile next to the two oceans that's
already been placed then this should be
13 right I don't think the style of 13.
I think it's still a bit too high and
there's a few different reasons for this
first of all these two versions We just
mentioned here these are generally not
the first oceans to be placed they only
way these two tiles will actually be
placed as the first oceans is because
you yourself are placing them because
you are intending to grab the three
cards with maximum rebates afterwards
and while we added this tile up here
also almost never gets placed like in
general so I feel like we have to do a
little bit of adjustments here so with
maximum rebates this tile appears with
four but it's not that often that this
ocean gets placed so I think I would I
would say it's more like two to be
honest and I think a fair value of what
this style with the three cards are
worth is around nine because like I said
is not often that these two oceans gets
placed before somebody grabs these three
cards here and also you're kind of
restricting Yourself by placing a title
over here or like the tempo that would
say this tile has a bad portal and don't
you worry we're gonna talk plenty about
portals in a minute but before we do
that let's actually discuss the best
oceans on this map so as always it
depends on the game but usually these
two oceans are the first to be made the
oceans themselves comes with two plants
on them so that alone is good and also
it just enables all of these tasty
rebate spots around the little Lake here
and technically the six and eight to the
north east these are not worth this yet
until you place more oceans but this is
also why that the next oceans that will
usually get placed are these two so you
can see the theme here these two oceans
also come with one plant each and also
you just enable yourself to get this
golden little landscape here with three
eights well based in this system this
tile should be worth five but it could
be accurate it's worth a lot more
because like in quizzes I was talking
about it does have some juicy neighbors
but the thing is if I start rewarding
some tiles for having good neighbors
then this is just a rabbit hole from
which I have no idea how to navigate so
let's just say that this style is worth
five as long as you know that there's a
lot more things to consider you also
have to consider the good neighboring
Towers you have to consider teleport you
have to consider which oceans are
usually played first and you also have
to consider what are my opponents doing
this game so is the title with three
cards any good I think generally yes
like it's a great player myself I'm very
tempted to actually grab these three
cards in most games but preferably you
really want to grab this with a special
tile it could be natural preserved
restricted area nuclear Zone something
like this could also be the experimental
for us Prelude another goat called
Parker his superhero name is actually
Gods while his secret identity name is
spaga he said that while there's always
exceptions I think the general too long
didn't read of Elysium is don't put
cities on the three cards is that worth
the investment generally and any Tempo
Rush thread should prioritize plants
rebates in the middle or the left of the
board over the three cards those three
cards can get heavily overvalued early
on with people over investing to get
them so the point is if possible you
really want to claim the three cards
with a special tile but let's get back
to portals as you may have guessed the
point is that it's really hard to
scratch your own back if you don't have
a portal actually it's kind of weird the
way I'm phrasing it so that yeah
probably know where you guess that
actually the real Point here is that the
rules say that you must Place Greenery
next to a tile that you own if possible
so did I just make this comparison just
so I had an excuse to show you this
bottle mean that I like about a woman
scratching her back maybe the point is
it's kind of hard to get back to the
middle of the map once you've committed
and placed the tile on the edge of the
map and you might be thinking well
what's the big deal I can just buy a
city for 25 as a standard project to get
back into the middle of the map and now
oh you really don't want to do that it's
very expensive it's not worth it
especially not in the early game so if
you're thinking all right you're
spending way too much time on this
portal stuff it's really not that big of
a deal but I'm telling you I've spent
some time with these Tempo notes and the
top three words that they like to say
when I talk to them number three is
Portal number two is ocean and number
one is rebates I'm not kidding and also
a heat production I also love heat
Productions I actually scratch that new
list top four words amongst the top
ranked players on Steam number four heat
production number three portal number
two ocean number one rebate I'm serious
it's like catnip to these people they
just love to say these four words so
having all of this in mind I think these
numbers here are fair as long as you
keep in mind that there's no portal on
the three cards or well I'm saying no
portal but it's more like it's it's kind
of a bad portal if that makes sense it
takes a while to get to the middle so
when also done the middle part of the
map is the best place to be your can
also go for the cards if you feel greedy
but to be honest like I mentioned it can
also just be the temple guy who just
needs the cat you know anthracad made a
good point here as well he said that
it's important to understand that these
rebates are worth two times to face
values in two player games as if you
don't capture them yourself your
opponent will this makes them
deceptively powerful swings if you
develop two cash Pro that doesn't cost
your opponent anything but if you take
the three plants but not only do you
gain three plans your opponent loses
them so I mean if you want to take what
he says literally then you could
actually double all the values on these
into your player games I don't know it
gets a little bit out of control you
know what I mean it's not quite like
this so the overall values are like this
but like I said I kind of feel like the
right side is a little bit too strong in
this case which is why I would like
adjust it a little bit so it looks more
like this and speaking of anthracite I
showed some of my slides to the guys in
the Discord group and answers I was like
Oh okay that's cool I actually had a
conversation once upon a time with this
guy Stefan if and we like came up with
this map here so as you can see it's
pretty similar which makes sense when
you think about it because anthro said
also puts plans to be worth too the only
difference really is that on anthocytes
and Stefan if's map it's like cards are
worth 4 whereas I put cards to B3 and
then the map they have made is like the
perfect scenarios for all of the tiles
so it's of course what they're going for
so I'm not blaming them but at the same
time it doesn't really reflect how the
tiles should look like I think the best
example I can give on this map is that
they put the tile with the three cards
to be worth 16 which is of course way
too high and the reason they put this
towel to be 16 is of course they just
calculated with maximum rebates which is
a little bit unrealistic and also they
put a random card to be worth four and
also they didn't take into account that
this tile has a bad portal the Meister
said I think the evaluation of the three
card spot is very high compared to the
other spots is right the main issue as
you already wrote is that the bad
position that you usually lock yourself
into if you go there also the Eastern
spots needs a lot of oceans to yield the
rebates while the sensor only needs two
Central oceans to unlock a ton of cash
if you take three cars you usually miss
their and thus they're only worth it if
you're really desperate or you have
another teleport Park also agreed with
this he said yeah if you have an awful
hand and you need cards to build you up
of a crappy start maybe cards is okay if
you have a city Prelude plus that's a
city then maybe cards is okay three
plants with the other although even here
a city on three plans and one left to
the ocean seems slightly better getting
the three characters like some biolab 3
Cup draw where you can just your
start and Bot control if those three
cards flop so it is generally agreed
upon that the right side of the map with
the three cards over here those tiles
should be nerfed a little bit because
these tiles do come with a lot of
drawback I think infrasad himself would
also agree with this the thing is he
didn't make this map for educational
purposes it's literally just a
conversation he had a long time ago with
this guy Stefan F so imagine making a
map like this just because you're just
having a casual conversation I'll tell
you guys these guys are absolute nerds
It's amazing and then they also
made this map here which in anthracite's
own words is a way to think about sea
replacement potential stating the rebate
value of placing a city there and
surrounding it with Greenery so it's
really cool that they also mapped out
the best places to be if you're building
a city and there's really no surprise
that the best place to build the city is
in the middle of the map so this tile
here is the highest with a value of 36
which is no surprise because this is
generally agreed upon that this is the
best place to place a city then also the
towers right next to it are good we got
30 in this style and 30 on this tile
then the tile Inquisitor was talking
about has a value of 28 and apparently
the one right next to it is 29 but I
think that's a little bit misleading
because the top left ocean almost never
gets played and once again these values
to the right side of the map are a
little bit too high like we talked about
generally it's not the best place to
build a city over here so with all of
this in mind let's look at how
especially Timber players likes to build
on this map and you get the idea by now
that just want to make a bunch of oceans
put a bunch of greeneries next to the
oceans just end the game as soon as
possible incredibly boring and then once
they've done something like this then
they might put two oceans over here to
the right and then they might claim the
three cards with a nucleus zone or
something but you know I'm
oversimplifying a little bit I think if
they have a special are like nuclear
Zone they will probably take the three
cards a little bit sooner so a typical
Timber game with the highest level on
the master for example it could really
look something like this it's a little
bit oversimplified I think they would
put in some special tiles to actually
block each other off from rebates and
stuff like this but aside from that this
is pretty much how they would like to
play I even showed these pictures to
some of the guys on the Discord and
they're like yeah it looks pretty good
to me however this just looks like a
plant Cellar to be honest like no cheese
no no dressing just a bland salad with
no joy no enjoyment whatsoever and you
might be thinking there's not even one
city here there's even a spot here where
you could get three points for City but
in these super fast tempo games cities
are just not that important I had a
YouTube comment on one of my videos by
Mac bashaiden who said I don't agree
with the argument that you have to build
a city in a game why I've had games
where I did nothing in Mars and won by
Miles and initially I just said to him
well for no other reason that plant
production is really strong in this game
so having just one city is often pretty
nice so you have a reliable way of
scoring points with your own greeneries
next to your cities but I agree with you
that sometimes it's not even necessary
to have one city but in my experience in
most caves having at least one city
feels correct so I thought about it some
more and really to be precise in Greedy
games you should always have at least
one city in Tempo games however you
might only have one city or maybe no
cities at all so that's pretty much what
I replied to this guy recently I also
said to him having games where you have
nothing unmasked at all is not
recommended as plan production it's just
way too good in this game and I want to
make this clear plant production is
great in literally every strategy which
means that you should have at least a
few greeneries on the map in literally
every single game we can actually go
through the strategy real quick to show
you what I mean so in the first round
they refuse to terraform yes you're
gonna have plant production the second
strategy where you are the filter Toyota
terraformer obviously you're gonna have
plant production in the third strategy
where you go for the car strategy where
you just want to go for a long game and
make a ton of points yes you're also
gonna have plant production in this case
because the thing is you're gonna have
discount on cards you're gonna have a
ton of Green Tech Synergy and also it's
just a very nice way to score points
having a bunch of playing production so
plant production is always good and then
strategy 5 and 6 are pretty much
extensions of the card strategies
strategy number five German tax ah sure
let's go play in production strategy
number six green tags of course like I
mentioned then you're also gotta have
band production and finally the mid game
strategy where you don't know yet if you
want to go for the long game or just
terraform like crazy like no matter what
you want playing product plan production
is always good which means you should
always have some greeneries on the map
so like I mentioned in simple games you
may only have one city it could be like
here which is the best city spot it
could also be here or here or here but
you know it really depends on the game
could also be the case that you want to
build a city here because then you can
access all of the plans on this side of
the map so building Greenery like this
in Greedy games where you really
maximize to get a lot of VP and go for
the long game I think the map should
look a little bit different so me being
a greedy player I would tend to favor
the cards in a lot of cases so like we
talked about you should really try to
have a special tile on the three cards
then for even more great you could put
mining area on top of the two steel here
or you can put an ocean to get this card
over here alternatively if the three
cards have already been taken you can
put restricted area over here on the two
titanium because that will allow you to
put mining area up here on the titanium
but these are just examples it could
also be that even though you're playing
the greedy game you still want to just
like put a tile in the middle of the map
here because then you're kind of
blocking the tempo players they cannot
get what they want in the middle of the
map then it could look something like
this if you're lucky you can get capital
in the middle of the map here but
usually once there are four oceans
placed I mean this style is usually
taken before you get to play Capital but
just a thought then if we continue with
this yeah let's be honest this dream
then we can also build over here or we
can build over to the right if you have
a mangrove or something you can also go
south usually because there's some
desert settler you want to win so like I
said there's probably a dream that's not
happening to be honest but I just wanted
to show you how I would build a map if I
just really maximize to get the most
points as possible so since we'll be
greedy here I would tend to favor the
card and look at this color palette man
it's beautiful we got cheese we got the
dressing we got cool tongues it's like
this salad looks very tasty to me so
basically what I'm saying is in Super
Creative games you place your Series in
a way so they can score the most VP as
possible and just for a second compare
this beautiful map to this super boring
temper player map oh my God now let's
look at the fastest map which is
actually the map from the base game is
just called fastest like the corporation
just to confuse you so first of all
let's look at the best oceans to place
on this map so usually amongst the top
players these are the first three oceans
to be played on this map the best place
to be is in the middle of the map near
the river if you can get away with it
it's also pretty tasty to just place an
ocean here and then Place something next
to it like a special tile or something
it could also be a city but like we
talked about in Tempo games especially
you don't really play that many cities
the point is that this tile in
particular is really important to
control and the reason is that later on
once the oceans gets placed there are
some really tasty spots for ocean
rebates right next to this title and you
might be thinking hey what what about
the two cards and yes you are correct if
you are a greedy player like me you will
grab the two cards as soon as possible
but even if you I'll agree the player
there's no denying that these oceans
here are usually the best just keep in
mind that you kind of want to have
something on the map if you place these
oceans because otherwise you're just
setting up your Tempo opponent to take
the really good router rebates and of
course if you are the greatest player
the two titanium can also be nice and we
could go on so here are the most
important spots for ocean rebates with
this very simple calculation a card is
worth 3 steals with two titaniums with
three plants with two and you might be
thinking that Tyler just mentioned the
tile up here is only worth four but it
can really be accurate that this style
is worth a lot more as it got some
really juicy neighbors this is the best
starting tile you could even make the
argument that this tile is worth eight
or something we could also go a step
further and include these tiles here
especially in the north there are some
high numbers as well but once again if
you take these water rebates you just
have to keep in mind that these rebates
have very bad portals because like I
said the best place to be in this map is
in the middle of the map and to
illustrate this point about the portals
I actually have a game in my channel
where I got in a little bit of trouble
because I put the mohal area up here on
the two cups don't think it's bad to go
for the cards but considering this was a
four player game and considering that my
strategy was to close the game as soon
as possible this was definitely the
wrong location so just to give you some
perspective from one of these top Timber
players Jeffrey Colbert mentioned that
this is definitely the wrong location
for local area he also said that
business contacts where just draw some
cards even this much slow you down
because Tempo is so important in these
Tempo games and they said well it might
actually be okay just because now you
need to find a new tailboat to go to the
river I'm not going to read all of this
you can pause the video if you want but
basically I said to him is it really
that bad to take the cards in this case
I even got insulation which was a huge
pickup and then I asked him if you were
playing where would you have put the
Mobile area and he said under one
planned elbow bent ocean so I think he
was talking about this spot here he did
say one plan so that would technically
be the tile right underneath this one
but I'm guessing this style here is
better maybe this is what he meant just
because this style has two planes
instead of one plan this would probably
be better but the point is more like now
I have a portal to get to the middle of
the map so later on when I play some
shrimps I have some nice water rebates
so I'm going to show you how this game
shaped out I had a ton of heat
production but I didn't have very much
Plan production at least not in the
first half of the game and by the way
this game had two green players don't
ask me how that happened but all the
tiles that I'm controlling is the title
with the head of Jacob cruxelius but as
you can see it got in a little bit of
trouble here because of these cities
that my opponents played so my first
Greenery conversion was actually really
ugly I just get one steal and then I
give an opponent one Victory Point
luckily my economy was really strong in
this game because of all of the
terraforming I've been doing so I just
ended up building a city standard
project for 25. generally you kind of
don't want to do this because the
standard project is kind of bad
especially if you're going for the tempo
Strat but in this game I feel they could
get away with it because I'm a strong
economy and I really desperately needed
a portal to get to the Middle River I
actually placed my city up here which is
a little bit questionable not gonna lie
the thing is it just had so much plant
production I just wanted to maximize how
many points I could get out of my
greeneries but it is questionable I
think a better place for the city could
have been here right by the river and
then I could convert immediately right
next to it to deny this tasty spot from
my opponent and then if I wanted to I
could have even converted one more
Greenery in this generation thanks to
the planes I'm getting from the good
rebate spots and in this case it didn't
really matter that much because soon
after I also claimed the city to the
South near the river and then I also had
noctic City in my hands so there's a
nice little Empire I'm getting here it's
fine so I think these values here are
pretty fair I don't think there's
anything I would adjust on this map so
once again if we just compare this to
the map anthracide and Stefan if made a
while ago you can see we're pretty much
in agreement the only difference is that
they put a random card to before and I
put a random card to B3 and when it
comes to the best city placements on
this map I would say that this city spot
here is the best one I know I only put
this title before but like I said it
could easily be more because look at all
of these neighbors here it's really good
but if this spot has already been taken
which is very likely then I think I
would be tempted to take the city over
here especially if we are on the first
generation if no oceans has been placed
yet then I think this spot for a city is
pretty good because there's so many
plants over here and if these two series
spots has been taken I think these two
also got Plan B they don't actually come
with any placement bonus themselves but
they have very good neighbors as you can
see here and the noxicity of course also
makes a lot of sense but the thing about
this city is you don't want to play it
too early I was playing a game where
anthracite was coaching me and we were
doing like a Tempo Strat like closing
the game as soon as possible and he
actually said that I should keep knocked
the city in my starting hand even and I
was like well isn't it bad because isn't
Tempo really important but he said no
we're just gonna keep it for the entire
game and then we're gonna play it in the
last generation because the thing is the
power of this car is not actually the
mid credit production it's very
expensive to just get three Mega credit
production for 18 plus the car plus an
energy production so that surprised me a
little bit in a Timber game where we
just wanted to close the game as soon as
possible anthracite told me to keep not
the city in my opening hand just so I
could play it in the last generation so
a map that looks something like this
could make a lot of sense this is both
for Timber games and for greedy games
but once again if you are playing a
super fast simple game likely you're not
gonna have this many cities so if we
compare this to the map that anthracide
and Stefan F made for the best city
placement spots then we can see that the
best city by far is this one for 36 and
it makes a lot of sense and then if you
cannot get this spot here then the spots
next to it also makes a lot of sense so
we got 32 for this but here we got 28
for this spot here but really you kind
of want this bot here for 36 that's
definitely the best part and then we got
the city spot over here for 23 it's not
actually as high as this one this one is
24 but that's of course provided that
you'll get maximum ocean rebates for all
of it so I'll still say this city spot
is marginally better in the early game
because in the early game there are not
so many oceans being placed yet so if
I'm going for an Omega greedy game I
might even do something like this where
I'm going for the cards but even then I
still want this really good CD spot near
the river and once again it doesn't have
to be a city it can also be experimental
for us or some of these special tiles
and speaking of the special tiles the
two special tiles I put over here to the
left of the map they are a little bit
questionable like if you look at the
value it's only a value of three by
placing here but as I am a little bit
biased towards getting cards I might
even do this and it also has a little
bit side bonus because then you can also
play smiling area next to these Styles
but these are just examples I mean in
this case if you really did get mining
area you would of course put it up here
next to the two ocean and then the
timber notes will probably tell you that
getting cards is kind of bad but if you
are getting the card to the South you
should probably take the cat next to it
because this has a better portal to the
ocean rebate you know but if I am being
greedy I would probably build something
like this and then at the end of the
game it could look something like this
and then of course we should throw in
ecological storm somewhere because this
card is also really good so let's
compare this greedy map to how the
timber players would like to build and
it looks something like this so it's all
about getting the plus two Mega credits
for being next to Ocean it's all about
getting all of the plants it's all about
ending the game as soon as possible and
it's so ugly man it looks like a bland
salad we got no tomatoes no croutons
nothing but even though it's incredibly
ugly there's no denying it is a valid
play of how you can play the game so in
this game for example I went for a Tempo
game my internet generation 9 and the
map looks like this and here is a
screenshot from a game between random
running and demise there who are both 2K
players and as you can see the map looks
like this so this is definitely a way
you can play the game it does make a lot
of sense in these Tempo games because
then you're just valuing all the rebates
over the point you're getting from
cities and stuff so it is something you
can do but if you really want to build
like this you should be ashamed of
yourself now let's look at the helles
map and just to give you a little bit of
insight we were talking about these maps
and Inquisitor said that Hillis is
actually the map everyone loves to hate
because it's an engine builder stream so
this is a nice place to start is this
map actually better for engine builders
and for the greedy strategy and yes I do
kind of agree with Inquisitor it makes a
lot of sense because on this map it's
very hard to Ocean Walk with greeneries
and also the thing is there are two
different bodies of oceans on this map
so if you are ocean walking next to one
of the bodies of oceans then you can
only teleport to get to the other one it
can be a little bit annoying for the
timber players and also I think
milestones and awards slightly favor
engine builders on this map and what I
mean is like is only polar explore and
cultivator that really caters to the
timber engine the rest of it really
benefits you to have a lot of cards and
like I mentioned plan production is also
really good for the greedy players so
even the cultivator it might not be the
temple player who has the highest chance
of getting this award so when Inquisitor
is saying that hillers is the Indian
Builder stream I think this makes a lot
of sense in most of the games in the
early game there are only two preferred
areas on this map either you can go to
the north where all the plants are you
could go to the South to go for the
polar Explorer or maybe you just want
the really cheap ocean so once again if
you put in all the values with Max ocean
adjacency bonus then it looks something
like this and it's a little bit all over
the place in this map and once again we
got a very underappreciated tile with
some very juicy neighbors especially in
the early game I think this style here
is one of the ones you want to go for
let's compare this to the map that
anthra said and Stefan if made and the
first thing that I'm wondering is why is
this tile worth four because it doesn't
really fit with their pattern their
pattern is just strictly math they're
not taken into account anything except
for math but generally speaking we
pretty much in agreement this style
should definitely have more values than
just the two because they have some
really good neighbors and they're
putting a random card to be worth four
why I would put a random card to be
worth three but once again they I don't
think they made this for occasional
purposes they literally just had a
conversation so I'm not going to give
them a hard time however it's kind of
interesting that all of us landed on
eight when we were evaluating how much
this style should be worth where you can
get one extra ocean for six Mega credits
I don't know how they thought about it
but my thinking is that if a terraform
rating is worth eight in the early game
then a placement bonus on top of water
is worth around six so I think this
makes a lot of sense and I just gotta
say that I know that these guys were
just taking the perfect scenarios for
all of the tiles but this title in
particular in the middle of the ocean
where you get three hits there's no way
this is worth 15 man if you think about
it if you set a hit to be worth one Mega
credit which is what it looks like they
did in the other parts of the map then
you will have to get literally perfect
rebates for this style to be worth 15
and that's just not happening alright so
like I mentioned you can build in the
South because you're going for the polar
Explorer Milestone or you just want the
G version and you might be thinking
where should this ocean go and if you
are the greedy player I think it makes a
lot of sense to just take the two
titanium you can even take the card if
you're desperate but it's not as good
but here's the thing if you're building
in the South it can be a little bit
awkward because you might like a
Teleport to go to the north to get the
plants so for example in the first
generation if you put a tile on top of
the free ocean and then that free ocean
replaced to the north to get some of the
plants up there well now you don't have
a portal to get up there because if
you're converting into greeneries you
have to place them next to a towel that
you own but maybe you have another
portal in hand maybe you have research
Outpost or something to get up north to
get close to all of these plants in that
case it's of course fine because on this
map it generally looks like this where
you start the game by playing these two
oceans at the top left and then
afterwards you put greeneries next to
these oceans like this so in most games
players are doing it like this even if
you don't have a CD and the thing is
there's so many plants up here so it
just makes a lot of sense to build these
two oceans and just convert next to the
ocean to get the rebates and then if you
have a cheap City it makes a lot of
sense to put it here or you can just
continue to Ocean Walk if you're going
for a Timber game you can also put a
city over here it makes a lot of sense
you've got a lot of plants you've got a
few ocean rebates and also there's a cop
close by so so it doesn't have to be
here exactly but generally speaking I
think these are the two best city spots
it could also be the city here that I
personally am fond of just because it's
next to two cards and the cheap ocean
once again let's look at the map where
anthracado stiff and F calculated the
best city spots so it's no surprise that
this tile up here is generally the best
place you can place a city apparently
the one underneath it to the left is
also worth 28 but I think this one is a
little bit worse because it's generally
agreed upon that once deals worth a
little less than one plant which means
that a city up here is slightly better
and then they put in this spot as one of
the best spots for a city and I think
this is a little bit questionable this
is like assuming that you'll get perfect
rebates for the ocean and also they put
the cards to be worth four so I think
this is a little wrong I would much
rather have a city up here for 22. that
makes more sense to me and then this bot
down here where I talked about this
questionable City this is Worth 22 so
it's not bad but they feel displacement
is a little bit better because it's next
to one titanium and next to one of the
ocean rebates worth two Mega credits but
me personally I would still take the one
to the left closer to the cards so if
you're ocean walking placing a lot of
greeneries next to Ocean then you kinda
need a Teleport to get to the other body
of oceans and that can be a little bit
awkward so the oceans and the rebates to
the left are a little bit better to
begin with because they come with more
plants like if you think about it the
first ocean you can place over here to
the right it will only yield you like
one card or one plant or something and
even after you place the first Ocean the
Second ocean is also gonna be kind of
weak but then it picks up the pace a
little bit because the third ocean
you're gonna place is gonna be worth
four or six or something like this and
then the last ocean you place on this
island is gonna be worth six at least so
if you have a strategy where you just
plan on placing a bunch of oceans then
it could make sense to build on the body
of oceans to the right because these
ocean rebates get gradually better and
better the more oceans you're placing
but that being said I think is still
slightly better to play around the body
of oceans to the left because this area
just has more plants the typical game
for Timber players could look something
like this where you have one city here
to like connect it all or you will have
to get like a second portal to actually
get to the other body of oceans so it
could look something like this and I
know what you're thinking you're
thinking I'm about to say that this
looks like a bland salad with no
tomatoes no croutons no cheese no
dressing but I'm actually not gonna do
that because even the greedy player like
me I can appreciate when I see something
beautiful and this kind of looks cool it
looks like an Omega flower or something
like that so I even showed this picture
to some other guys and I even asked them
anyone ever managed to build greeneries
all the way around these seven ocean
tiles like this and molaram he answered
no but it's beautiful even more so if
you put a mangrove in the middle and
that just blew my mind it's never
happening obviously but it's so pretty
to think about so I should probably
Gather By now these ocean rebates are
really highly valued especially on the
high level so this also means that
denying your opponents these rebates is
also really important so how can you
actually counter these Master ocean
rebaters first of all you can just cut
them off from rebates you can also steal
their rebates also don't Place oceans
that will help your opponents and also
you can just focus on your own game so
we're going to talk about all of this
but the first thing we're going to talk
about is cut them off from rebates
because temper players will play a bunch
of greeneries next to Oceans so for
example here is your typical Tempo
player if you cut him off from Ocean he
will get really frustrated and then if
you keep doing this he will get straight
up mad I'm telling you guys cutting
these Timber players off from rebates is
right up there with telling them that he
production is bad they'll get furious so
I have a few examples here so recently I
started playing random steam just to see
how high I can get and one of the few
games I lost before reaching 1800 is
against this guy Inquisitor who's a
really strong player so I started this
game placing an ocean with a preload or
something and then a played restricted
area next to it just to get the three
cards it's a pretty good play I would do
it again probably especially in this
game I think it was correct because my
hand was terrible so I just needed to
find some better cars to play but now we
see the issue of this play because this
style has no portal or limited access if
you will so Inquisitor being the good
player that he is he plays his first
Greenery right here so he's kind of
counting me off from rebates and he's
cutting me off from the middle of the
map like we talked about that is the
good place to be and the latest or I
built a city to cut him off from rebates
so this is my second portal if you will
now I have access to the middle of the
map and then he build protected Valley
so now he also has a second portal and
to be honest in this particular game it
wasn't really that big of a deal because
I wasn't really playing the map that
much I didn't find any plan production
except for that one playing production I
have so in this game in particular it
didn't matter that much about all the
blocking off of rebates and stuff like
this but I'd more like to show you how
these guys are thinking about the game
like really thinking about ocean rebates
and really thinking about how to block
the other guy so he doesn't have access
to the good places on the map that's
something the top ELO guys on Steam are
really thinking a lot about when they
play and just to illustrate my point
soon after this Inquisitor blocked me
off completely once again by playing
land claim and Industrial Center and
normally it would be sad about losing
but in this game he almost made a flower
in the middle of the map which I thought
was quite beautiful here's another game
played recently against this guy Parker
Parker or if you've watched student you
probably know him better as Gods he's a
Dota 2 commentator but as of this game I
believe he was like the third highest
rated player on Steam so it's a very
strong player but in this game he
started off playing experimental Forest
on of course the best tile in the game
like we talked about and then I played
commercial District which is a little
bit questionable but I think it was
still fine in this case but I played
commercial District over here with the
other plans and already here there was
actually an opportunity to place my
commercial District next to his Greenery
just to be very annoying and to cross
him off from future rebates but I didn't
do that so God he made two oceans and
then he made this Greenery here and now
he's really ready to start ocean walking
but then I played this land claim here
completely messing up his plan so that's
gonna be very frustrating for him and
then he got protected Valley which is
basically his second portal so now he
can begin ocean walking to the south of
the river and then the black team again
by playing Dome Creator but to be honest
it's not that big of a deal because he
already has access to the south of the
river so this block doesn't do that much
but then I played ecological Zone and
then immediately I converted right next
to the ecological zone so this was a big
hit because remember these two tiles are
the best tiles in the game these two
tiles are worth 10 mega Critters per
tile so I'm getting these two sales for
myself which is really the good but even
more important I'm actually denying Gods
these two tiles because he's all in on
terraforming so these two tiles is
definitely something he wanted and also
remember anthracite's point from earlier
that if you're playing a two-player game
then these tiles are sort of kind of
double in value because I'm getting
these tiles but also Gods is not getting
these tiles and to be honest I still
lost this game because scarcity closed
the game in generation 9 and I made a
few huge mistakes that I'm gonna talk
about on episode 6 but that being said
my titling was still kind of good it's
still a good thing to actually block him
off from rebates so God's kinda got the
last laugh in this one so he turned back
into this nice little innocent happy
flower here and to be honest this is
probably a more fair representation of
what God is actually like he's actually
a super chill dude he's one of the
nicest guys I've ever met so just like
cutting people off from rebates is
really important you should also steal
their rebates if possible so stealing
their rebates is a big swing at both
Mega credits and plans and even if you
give them VP for planting next to their
city it's still worth it most of the
time and like anthracite was talking
about is X very important to steal
rebates in two-player games so the most
extreme example I have of this is an
entirely different game where I played a
much lower rated opponent so his first
city was really good it's only good spot
and then my first conversions is next to
knock to city so we sort of blocked me
down here I suppose but it's really not
a big deal because I wasn't planning on
going this way with my greeneries
instead I built the city up here and
then also steal his first rebate and
then I place this land claim here which
is really good because I know that later
in the game this tile itself gave him 10
mega credit worth of value so I just
continued to steal his rebates and you
probably know where this is going I
actually end up stealing all of his
rebates from the city so I actually
planted five greeneries around his City
or in other words I almost reversed
flowered him and to be clear reverse
flower is actually not an expression I
just made that up so I plan the five
greeneries around his City and you might
be thinking what are you crazy I just
gave him five victory points but the
thing is I also stole from him one steal
five plants and 20 Mega credits so in
total what I stole from him is 32 Mega
credits worth of value so is that better
than five victory points I would argue
yes and once again remember this idea
that these values are kind of double
because we are playing a two player game
and to be honest some of the greeneries
I played around his City also helped my
city but even if it didn't I think this
would still be worth it and another way
to counter these Master ocean rebaters
is simply to not Place oceans that will
help your opponents so if you do not
intend to play the map then it might
actually be better to not create the
best oceans in the middle of the map
because then you're just helping your
opponent right what I mean is if you
place these four oceans and then you do
nothing then well you're just setting
your opponent up to place all of these
juicy spots we discussed before so if
you're placing these four oceans it must
be because you yourself are intending to
play something next to these oceans
here's a much easier representation of
how not to help your opponent so let's
say your opponent already placed this
city maybe had research Outpost or
something in that case you should not
place this water because then you're
just helping him because now you've just
given your opponent a nice way to claim
these ocean rebates next to his City so
that's not good and finally you could
just focus on your own game I mean if
you are a greedy player if you just want
to go for the long game just play your
game it's fine but actually this is a
little bit of a terrible piece of advice
because at the very least you should
block him with like a land claim or
special tile or something you should do
something to interrupt his Little Empire
of ocean walking so technically this one
should be just focused on your own game
but at the same time block him as much
as possible finally I want to talk about
the aquifier is this a good stand-up
project because the master said
something very interesting he said also
something that dawned on me very late is
the value of rebates I think you don't
value them as highly as you're not
really on board with the SP ocean which
is one of the most crucial SP for the
early game in my opinion I also didn't
realize their value when trying to math
every production out correctly oceans
plants and tiles have a huge amount of
value if you combine them and this
actually is what makes the timber place
so strong you get those oxygen points
but you also get a lot of hashback when
you play Your Greens especially on
Elysium and fastest so basically the
Meister here is describing exactly why
the tempo strategy is so strong and I
agree that the Tempest thread is really
good but I still am not on board with
ASP ocean so I replied to him that
regarding ocean rebates I can appreciate
how four or six Mega Critters and two
plans can be powerful especially
considering you could play Oceans as
your first action and then Greenery
special tiles or something next to it
but even still you don't always get the
dream placement like this so what is an
average placement bonus of an ocean with
if the plants you get is exactly the
plans you need in order to convert into
a Greenery then is great otherwise I
just can't agree that it's a crucial
standard project in the early game it's
still rather expensive we just
established that the Tia is worth around
8 Mega credits in the early game and
then declining this means that the value
of a placement bonus on the ocean itself
should be like 10 mega credits I know
that you guys love your rebates but geez
ocean cards I can understand but
personally I'm not that crazy about the
ocean standard project so originally it
said that I placement bonus is around
four and that means that you're
overpaying by six I'm willing to meet
the Meister halfway and say that a
placement bonus is worth around six and
therefore you're only overpaying by four
but why does the Meister who is a strong
player still think that ocean standard
project is good in the early game I
think it's because like he alluded to
there are some hidden bonuses of placing
an ocean first of all it's important to
understand that you have two actions so
you can set yourself up to get a better
rebate as your second action also if
you're placing an ocean on Plants it may
allow you to convert into a Greenery
immediately and finally and this one is
just me being a little bit biased
against these Tempo nerds but to be
honest this is part of it if you are
playing the tempo game then you want to
close the game so placing this aquifier
standard project just helps you close
the game and that's pretty much all for
this video so special thanks to all of
the top ELO players on Steam I actually
do appreciate all the input they've
given me even though I've made fun of
them a little bit calling them Tempo
nerds and stuff like this if you do feel
like I've been a tad too offensive
regarding the whole Timber nerd thing
then I would ask that you direct all all
of your anger towards the Meister who
practically forced me to do it as
evidenced by the conversation here at
the bottom of the screen so yeah do that
thanks for watching
so how can you actually counter these
Ocean Master rebalers laughs